hey everyone how's it going it's my Yuka
today I am here with Jarvis I was
spending quality time with my family why
did you bring me here
you're here now oh so it is the holidays
and I thought it would be fun to do
something a little different on my
channel and play a little game so the
game that I thought we would play
together is never have I ever and the
holiday twist that I'm adding is to
figure out who's gonna be on the nice
list and the naughty list so before we
started Jarvis has been on my channel
before but I thought maybe you can
introduce yourself a little bit
hi I'm Jarvis I make videos about life
and tech and sometimes there is a comedy
so welcome back to my channel I'm happy
to get back so the way that we're gonna
play never have I ever is we're going to
choose first off with my fingers and
Scott behind the camera is going to read
off like never have I ever statements
and so if we have done those things
before and then we're gonna put a finger
down and eventually you might get down
to 0 so whoever gets down to 0 first
loses what yeah and then one by not
losing cool shall we start the first
line let's start it alright Scott what's
the first one never have I ever broken
something at someone's house hold up no
I kind of have wait wait I haven't
actually oh yeah usually I have a midst
guilt and I would tell someone I think
something has happened like oh hey your
toilet is clogged oh hey something is
happening like I usually will come to
the goodness to be like and mostly
because I get anxious and I'm like I
need to tell them cuz I'm worried that
they're gonna think I did it or the
other anyway yeah what's your story so
my story is like when I was in
elementary school I used to be in Girl
Scouts and I remember one time like I
was chewing gum and we went to this like
person's house I don't know why we were
there but I really needed to spit out my
gum and we were just like walking around
her backyard and I was like I news about
this gum so like I went to her garden
and there was like this plant I just
picked part of the leaf off and spit my
gum out in it and so it's like kind of
breaking something at
someone's house but part of the leaf
yeah
just brotherly but I was so guilty for
like a year after that it's actually
like an elementary school can you ever
go back I like look at how the plan was
to know I didn't know where it was but I
was just like oh my god like a kill trip
plan I killed your whole garden and
she's gonna find out she she's never
gonna want to invite the Girl Scouts
over ever again
it just consumed my mind like a good
year oh my gosh yeah we just now I try
the furni because it's like ultimately
like not that big of it yeah when you
were like oh I have done that yeah I've
kind of broken something and not told
them about it one time I took off a part
of a leaf and I was guilty about it for
20 years never have I ever cried so I
flirted so I just talked my way out of a
speeding ticket okay so I haven't done
this with a speeding ticket but I have I
told the creative truth to get myself
out of a Muni ticket system in San
Francisco ha ha ha I read a bust and I
didn't tap on because I was a poor
college student of as an exam Francisco
and there were police officers waiting
at the beauty station chucked us and
then I was like I don't I'm from Florida
I just I was living there for the summer
yeah I don't know anything I'm just a
tourist from Florida well technically
this is true but yeah I've never gotten
a speeding ticket
so another have that experience
nightmare it is so super-clean okay
never have I ever broken a bone I guess
I would yeah
never have I ever broken my nose playing
laser tag oh and I was out playing later
shower with friends and I turned and
there's this wall and I saw the
reflection of lasers on the wall
so I ran full speed nose first and I
rubbed my nose I really won't wearing
kids like so many people broke their
bones then I almost thought the
late-breaking
like a cool thing to do because he can
get a cool like cast that people can
sign no III do like I feel like people
are like that with glasses see like
broken bones glass is also allergies
also is kind of a things like allergies
and they called me snot-nosed oh well I
think all of these like so I got classes
in like fourth grade so I eventually
that caught up there but all the other
things were like because like everyone
else have them but me and I thought
that's out right because they were urine
theory you really the superior rested
thankfully have you so I have
technically been arrested but being
arrested doesn't really mean anything
like a cop can arrest anyone
yeah it doesn't mean if they're at any
sort of fault so I grew up in a college
town and there were a lot of 18 and up
bars and clubs and thing or not bars is
you nut bars yeah hurry it up clubs my
dance clubs and stuff in my 18 year old
friends when I was 18 would like to do
an illegal thing which is like drink
alcohol and then like go to these clubs
bringing one night they were going and I
was there also but I wasn't drinking
because I used to be really afraid to
drink and I was in the car I was in the
passenger seat and everybody was like
stopped and we're about to get out of
the car and I looked in the rearview
mirror and I saw police officers walk
and they have like the people do like
work driving and I was the only silver
one because for no reason other than me
just not feeling like drinking and then
the officer comes up and like Nakhla but
we did get out of the car and then I can
align us all up and they're like take
everybody's IDs I'm not here under
arrest
I was like excuse me officer
I had nothing you could breathalyze me
I'm totally clean
then they let me go so I was technically
arrested yeah but I ain't wrong so that
is it I think that is all the prompts
that we have I don't actually know who
won because the points don't matter the
place no matter but thank you so much
for playing this game with me Jarvis
yeah I had a lot of fun not can I rejoin
my friends yeah in a moment okay uh
before Jarvis goes back to his friends
and family uh be sure to LIKE this video
and to subscribe to my channel if you
haven't done so already for future
videos also leave a comment for any of
the stories that you might have based on
like the prompts that we talked about
yeah yeah um drivers working everyone
find you on the interwebs so you can
find me at youtube.com slash Jarvis
Johnson and then you can find me on
Twitter at Jerez and on instagram at
magic yars because i didn't play the new
this thing and you can find me on all
three platforms as hello my you go miss
be nice that branding cool so I think
that's it thank you again and we'll see
you next time bye
so it is the holidays and so the game
that I thought we'd play is never have I
ever
[Music]